during a normal day in the Donald Donald
Trump administration we can be so
overwhelmed with the craziness and the
news that it's hard to keep up with
everything that happens and this past
week has been particularly wild right I
mean Trump fire James Comey the
revealing secrets to Russians in the
Oval Office thing it's been a crazy week
and that's why many people haven't
noticed that the director of the Census
Bureau John Thompson has suddenly
announced his resignation which will
take effect at the end of June this may
be as important as the departure of
James Comey I've been talking about the
census since November 9th probably even
before that the 2020 census and this is
huge the Census happens every 10 years
the Constitution outlines that the
census will take place the census
determines how federal money gets
distributed it determined how
congressional district lines are drawn
and it relates to gerrymandering it's
what makes people politically visible we
did recently did a long-form video about
gerrymandering and the impact that the
2020 census will have on redistricting
in the decade that follows this is going
to impact house elections for years to
come and it's at the core of what our
national politics will look like
Thompson
served in the position of Director of
the census since 2013 his term wasn't
supposed to end until next year and the
fact that there won't be a director is a
major issue the time leading up to the
2020 census it's critical people may not
realize this but the census is not
something that happens like in the year
before you actually do the census as
soon as one census is done the planning
starts for the next census and it
basically last 10 years we know how slow
Donald Trump is when it comes to filling
important leadership positions and even
when he fills those positions there's a
good chance that it's going to be an
ideologue and someone we should actually
not want running the census budget
problems can linger for agencies that
don't have a director because they don't
have someone there advocating for money
if the census is underfunded that's a
really bad thing
I'm very concerned about this and it's
not making almost any headlines I've
been talking about the census for months
months if not years it's so important
and now there's no one in charge of the
boat
well John Thompson who's the outgoing
census director has a background as a
statistician which is something that you
would expect out of someone in that role
to given Donald Trump's cabinet picks
you know people who are just
ideologically opposed with the positions
that they have to fulfill sure we can
only expect some someone like chris
Christie or like a Breitbart reporter or
a Wall Street guy to take over you're
right I mean the guy who trump appointed
to be effectively the head scientist of
the USDA is a Christian conservative
radio talk show host with no background
in science the guy who trump appointed
to be Secretary of Energy Rick Perry is
someone who didn't want the Department
of Energy to exist but actually forgot
that that was one of the departments he
wanted to abolish the guy who drains the
swamp by hiring his family members to
work in the White House and appointing
billionaires and Wall Street finance
executives and tycoons to important
positions in Washington is the guy who's
going to put someone in there who's
qualified to direct the census if Trump
puts someone qualified in to run the
census it will be a mere coincidence I
mean it won't be the result of proper
planning and selection and history has
also shown us that Trump may be likely
to nominate someone who is just hugely
partisan and that would be just as bad
as someone who's unqualified to run the
Census so I am so concerned about this
it can impact politics obviously it
impacts politics for 10 years but it can
also impact politics much longer if you
consider that then you will are more
likely to have Republicans deciding who
will head up the next census this is
really not a good thing yeah I think if
there's any silver lining here though is
that the census has a lot to do with
data where people live demographic
breakdown it's not too political where
it gets political is when you take that
information give it over to the state
legislatures and then they're in charge
of drawing the district lines
that's where gerrymandering comes in
that's where the the issue really takes
hold no doubt about it and we've been
covering that and we're going to
continue covering it today's episode of
the David Pakman show is made possible
in part by Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby
Parker recently did the right thing
and ditched advertising on right-wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five-day home Tryon from Warby Parker
check out their glasses I use them when
I'm not wearing contact lenses I started
with the free at-home trial they send
you five pairs of glasses you see which
one do you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription in - I like this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like in an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS